so um I want to recommend a book first
to everyone here it's called explaining
postmodernism and it's by a gentleman
named Stephen Hicks and you need to
understand postmodernism because that's
what you're up against and you're up
against it far more than you know or
think and it's a much more
well-developed
and uh pervasive pernicious nihilistic
intellectually attractive Doctrine than
has yet come to public realization it
absolutely dominates the humanities and
increasingly the social sciences in the
universities and what's happening you
see someone once said who unfortunately
I can't remember it might have been
friederick n said that everybody is the
unconscious exponent of a dead
philosopher and uh fortunately the
postmodern philosophers most of them are
dead so that's a good thing but that
doesn't mean that their words aren't
continually being spoken by people who
who are following in their wake let's
say and it's not like any given person
is absolutely possessed say by the
spirit of postmodernism because often
they're not educated enough to know all
the details about what it is that has
them in their grip but if you get 20 of
them together and they're all 5%
influenced by the postmodernist ethos
you basically have the spirit of the mob
that's a mouthpiece for that particular
philosophical Doctrine and if you
understand the doctrine then you
understand why things are progressing
the way that they're progressing and so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the doctrine um because it's not
optional to understand this it's
absolutely crucial to understand this uh
you you can't underestimate the power of
ideas and and also the Power of Words of
course because ideas are expressed in
words but you see the postmodernists
completely reject the structure of
Western civilization and I mean
completely so I can give you an example
in one term jacqu dereda whose head
trickster for the postmodernist movement
regarded Western culture let's call it
the patriarchy as phallogocentric okay
so phow comes from phus p l l o and so
that's the insistence that what you see
in Western culture is the consequence of
a male-dominated oppressive uh
self-serving society and we might say
well you know societies do tend to be
self-serving and people in power do tend
to act in their best interests but a
tendency is not an absolute and that's
one of the things that needs to be
considered continually there are no
shortage of flaws in the manner in which
we've structured our society and
compared to any hypothetical Utopia it's
an absolutely dismal wreck but compared
to the rest of the world and the plight
of other societies throughout the
history of mankind we're doing pretty
damn well and we should be happy to be
living in the society that we're living
in so the first thing that you might
want to note about postmodernism is that
it doesn't have a shred of gratitude and
there's something pathologically wrong
with a person who does have doesn't have
any gratitude especially when they live
in what so far is the best of all
possible worlds and so if you're not
grateful you're driven by resentment and
resentment is about the worst emotion
that you can possibly experience apart
from arrogance resentment arrogance and
deceit there's an evil Triad for you and
if you're bitter about everything that's
happening around you despite the fact
that you're bathed in wealth then
there's something absolutely wrong with
you you know the black community in the
United States is the 18th wealthiest
community 18th wealthiest Nation on the
planet now that doesn't mean there isn't
such a thing as relative poverty and
relative poverty matters it's an
important it's an important political
economic issue and it's very very
difficult to deal with but absolute
wealth matters too and and the Western
societies have been absolutely
remarkable in their ability to generate
and distribute wealth as you can tell by
just looking around and taking a you
know a brief bit of consideration for
the absolute miracle that even a
building like this represents so you
have to educate yourself about
postmodernism okay so here's what the
postmodernists believe they don't
believe in the individual that's the
logos part Western culture is fell
logocentric logo is logos that's partly
the Christian word but it's also partly
the root word of logic okay they don't
believe in logic they believe that logic
is part of the process by which the
patriarchal institutions of the West
continue to dominate and to justify
their dominance they don't believe in
dialogue the root word of dialogue is
logos again they don't believe that
people of Good Will can come to
consensus through the ex through the
exchange of ideas they believe that that
notion is part of the philosophical
substructure and practices of the
dominant culture so the reason they
don't let people who they don't agree
with speak on campus is because they
don't agree with letting people speak
you see it's not part of the ethos okay
so what else do they believe and not
believe they believe that you since you
don't have an individual identity your
fundamental identity is group fostered
and that means that you're basically an
Exemplar of your race hence White
Privilege or you're an Exemplar of your
gender or your sex or your ethnicity or
you're an Exemplar of however you can be
classified so that you you are placed in
the position of victim against the
oppressor because that's the game and
it's it's a it's a post-marxist slight
of hand right the old Marxist notion was
that the world was a Battleground
between the burgeois and the proletariat
and that uh failed to have any
philosophical or ethical standing that
argument after the working class
actually saw its standard of living
massively elevated as a consequence of
of Western corporate democracy uh
Western free enterprise
democracy and also be and and also as a
consequence of the revelations of
everything terrible that had happened in
every bloody country that ever dared to
make equity and and and the Marxist
communist Dogma part of their
fundamental structure right and nothing
but murderousness and oppression and so
by the 1970s it was evident that that
game was up the postmar the
postmodernist Marxist just barely
basically pulled a slight of hand and
said okay if it's not the poor against
the rich it's the oppressed against the
oppressor we'll just redivide the
subpopulations in ways that make our our
bloody philosophy continue in its in its
in its movement forward and that's where
we're at now and so for the
postmodernists the world is a Hoban
battleground of identity grp groups they
do not communicate with one another
because they can't all there is is a
struggle for power and if you're in the
Predator Group which means you're an
oppressor then you better look out
because you're not exactly welcome ah
not exactly welcome and neither are your
ideas so that's what you're up against I
would say it's time for conservatives to
stop apologizing for being conservatives
no
and you don't apologize to these people
that's a big mistake apology they're
they read apology as a as a as an
admission of guilt you don't apologize
and you don't back down you young people
that are out there who are University
students you need to take over the
student unions you need to take them
back because they're absolute snake pits
and they have been since the
1990s and with regards with regards to
the universities I thought at one point
that the best thing to do would be to
cut their funding by 25% and let them
fight amongst themselves for the
remnants because it would force the
universities to decide exactly what's
important and what isn't so I would say
the humanities and much of the social
sciences has has turned into a
post-modern neo-marxist playground for
Radicals the scholarship is terrible 80%
of Humanity's papers aren't cited once
once and so what that means is that they
write papers for each other and they
sell them to libraries and that's how
the Publishers make their money no one
reads them but the Publishers can print
them because the libraries have to buy
them and they're buying them with your
tax money and so all of you who are
sitting here are funding an a postmodern
radical neo-marxist agenda that has its
roots in the university and your tax
money is going towards that and if you
want proof of that you just go online
and look at the websites especially of
of disciplines like women studies which
is pathological right to the core but
it's not just women's studies it's all
the ethnic studies
groups it's anthropology it's sociology
it's social work and most of all it's
education and O for example in Ontario
is perhaps apart from the Ontario Human
Rights Commission the most dangerous
institution in Canada it
should it should be defunded it's as
simple as that they don't do the
research they purport to do they're not
interested in in in at all in education
they're interested in the indoctrination
of people as young as they can fi uh as
young as they can get their hands on so
to speak now we need to figure out our
society needs to figure out how to start
stop shunting public tax money to
radical left-wing activists if we were
doing that for radical right-wing
activists there would be an absolute
storm but it's happened incrementally
since the 1960s and it needs to stop so
that's that's partly what the the
conservatives not only conservatives but
also liberals true liberals in the
English sense are up against I mean
what's happened as also as a consequence
of this postmodern neo-marxist
intellectual invasion is that the center
keeps moving it's moved way to the right
now so if you're a classic liberal
you've become a conservative and so for
all of you who are interested in puru
pursuing the conservative agenda there's
a lot of classic liberals that you could
be talking to and then finally with
regards to talking to young people you
finally have something to sell to them
you know it's not easy to sell
conservatism to young people because
they want to change things and that's
not what conservatives want to do they
want to maintain things well now you've
got something to sell to young people
you can sell them freedom of speech and
you can tell sell them responsibility
the left is selling them rights you can
sell them responsibility and I can tell
you because I've received many letters
of the sort that that God was talking
about young people are absolutely
starving for someone to provide them
with a sense of responsibility and say
look here's something worth living for
man you know you can find meaning in
life with freedom but freedom freedom is
a chaotic sort of meaning right and and
freedom isn't the sort of thing that
makes people happy it's the sort of
thing that makes people people
Troublesome troubled because um Freedom
expands your your series of choices and
that makes you nervous and uncertain so
but responsibility is another not to say
that that's a bad thing it's a good
thing but it it it requires that you
that you shoulder the responsibility of
the freedom but responsibility per se is
what gives your life meaning genuine
meaning in the face of suffering and you
and young people are really they're
starving for that I've been teaching
young people for 30 years and mostly
what I've been teaching them about is
responsibility it's like your heirs to a
great tradition it's not perfect
obviously but comparatively there's
nothing else like it that's ever been
produced and it's it it represents a
tiny minority of of of of the human
polities most of which are are are are
run by murderous antisocial Psychopathic
um Thugs and that that seriously and so
what kind of alternative is that we've
got this Beacon of freedom and wealth in
the west that works although it doesn't
work perfectly and one of the one of the
responsibilities of young people is to
find out what's at the core of that the
great great core of that the the
Paramount the Paramount importance of
the individual and the Divinity of
speech man that's something to sell it's
what our whole culture is predicated
on all right well I should stop there so
thank you very much for the invitation
woo